joining me now is khalid hussaini the
legendary author of the kite runner and
two other acclaimed novels set in
afghanistan that have introduced
americans to what life was like in his
home country before it was terrorized by
taliban warlords just listen to his
description of the dreams of a young
girl in the novel a thousand splendid
sons
it was easy to tell mullah fazola things
that murriam didn't dare tell nana one
day as they were walking mariam told him
that she wished she would be allowed to
go to school i mean a real school
akansaheb like in a classroom like my
father's other kids mullah fazola
stopped the week before bibi joe had
brought news that jaleel's daughter said
naheed were going to the mary school for
girls in herat since then thoughts of
classrooms and teachers had rattled
around in murriam's head images of
notebooks with lined pages
columns of numbers and pens that made
dark heavy marks she pictured herself in
a classroom with other girls her age
mariam longed to place a ruler on a page
and draw important looking lines is that
what you want maleficent said looking at
her with his soft watery eyes his hands
behind his stooping back the shadow of
his turban falling on a patch of
bristling buttercups
yes
hussaini in my view has done more than
any other person to portray the unique
diversity and reality of human beings in
afghanistan he grew up in kabul before
moving to the u.s in 1980 when he and
his family were granted political asylum
he's also the founder of the khalid
husseini foundation an organization
providing humanitarian assistance in
afghanistan
thanks again for speaking with me
tonight
last week when you and i spoke you told
me how your heart was broken by what's
been happening in afghanistan i wonder
how do you feel today any less depressed
any more optimistic about the future at
all
honestly media
try to look for a positive angle moving
forward because that's something i've
always looked for i always
try to find a sliver of hope but right
now
things are pretty bleak
i'm watching the situation in the
airport
and while that's obviously very very
important that's happening right now i'm
also thinking long term about the future
of the country
and particularly about women and girls
you read the excerpt from from my book
and that speaks to one of my essential
concerns what will happen to women what
will happen to girls what will happen in
education what will happen to all the
rights that they have gained over the
last 20 years through blood sweat and
tears
yeah and
this is the big issue we talk about
afghanistan's mariams we just mentioned
from a thousand splendid sons a lot of
the people who didn't want to pull out
of afghanistan rightly or wrongly they
cited the progress made
over the last 20 years because it's easy
and it's right to highlight the costs of
the war the people who died and we've
done that extensively on this show i'm
someone who openly supported uh the u.s
withdrawal from afghanistan but it would
be wrong to deny the wins the progress
that was made especially for women and
girls and that undeniably is going to go
backwards even though this new
supposedly moderate taliban is claiming
that they will respect women's rights
they say
look when the taliban fled
in 2001 after the u.s camp campaign
began
there were roughly 900 000 children in
school in the entire country a nation of
some 30 plus million people
and they were
all of them boys
by 2020 over 9 million children were in
school and almost 40 percent of them
were girls
that is
very difficult to dismiss
millions of girls returned to school
they had hopes of
education of securing a future for
themselves and of becoming
you know
relevant players in the rebuilding of
this country
that is entirely up in the air now and
frankly at the mercy of the taliban
unless as i hope the international
community beginning with the us and her
partners bring legitimate diplomatic
pressure on the taliban to not abuse
the essential human rights of women and
girls and allow them access to education
to work and and and and other and
systems of justice
yes
and
i mean that's all that's left now is
that kind of international pressure and
pressure from some of our allies who do
have leverage over the taliban the
taliban is warning today of consequences
if the u.s delays its withdrawal of
troops beyond next tuesday's august 31st
deadline biden said today the us is on
track but he's also making contingency
plans are you filled with confidence
when you hear the president speak about
the timeline i mean on the one hand he's
been criticized for
you know botching the evacuation on the
other hand as he pointed out today
70 000 people evacuated just since
august 14th isn't a small amount of
people that is an achievement
yeah look i
i like president biden i voted for him
and giving the opponent i i would again
in a heartbeat
that said
he has said multiple times that we're
not going to leave until every last
american citizen is evacuated from
afghanistan and i would like to hear the
same about the u.s allies the afghan
afghans who risked their lives in
supporting and in many cases protecting
u.s troops
i'm thinking about those interpreters
and their families who are now
who believe i believe quite justifiably
that they are targets against the
taliban
i believe there is a moral mandate to
make sure that our partners the people
who risk their lives who sacrifice who
risk the lives of their families to
align themselves with u.s objectives are
protected and evacuated and god forbid
in the coming days and weeks if images
circulate of
afghan allies of the united states being
executed by the taliban that will be a
blood state would be very difficult to
wash off
it's a very good point and we do have a
moral and a strategic obligation to
those people
after 20 years of occupying that country
uh khalid what are you hearing from your
contacts on the ground in afghanistan
from your friends from your colleagues
from family members about what the
situation is like now especially outside
of kabul
well i have family in western
afghanistan and they're
frankly scared they're anxious they're
uncertain about what's going to happen
the us's withdrawal will be complete by
august 31st and then the taliban will
essentially take over and nobody knows
what the future holds for afghanistan
nobody knows what kind of government the
taliban intent to run they've been
saying some of the right things they've
been saying they will not abuse afghan
civilians that they will not abuse women
they will respect human rights uh but i
think quite rightly quite justifiably
millions of afghans uh are skeptical
about those words they remember the last
time the taliban ran the country they
remembered the ruthless ways in which
the brutalized and terrorized afghans
for the last 20 years and i think
they're quite rightly skeptical of what
the taliban are saying that is certainly
what i'm hearing from from family
members that i've spoken to and also
colleagues within kabul
khalid a new poll shows americans by
more than two to one say the war in
afghanistan was not worth it three out
of four predict the taliban-led country
will again become a haven for terrorists
looking to target the united states
president joe biden's approval rating
has taken a hit too yet only seven
percent of those surveyed believe he's
the president most at fault for what has
happened in afghanistan nearly two in
three in my view rightly blame the
commander-in-chief who started it all
george w bush i wonder though as an
afghan-american do you believe that the
conflict was worth it looking back at
the entire 20-year period
look i think it's a really a legitimate
question maybe and and then that one
that afghans are asking themselves
it is undeniable
that in the last 20 years significant
progress was made the challenges the
failures of the last 20 years have been
well documented
and i don't want to reiterate those
because your viewers are probably very
familiar with them from the failure to
form a legitimate government to the drug
trade to the inability to bring security
under control
but look millions of children went back
to school
women returned to the government
they became their return to the
workforce uh millions of afghans enjoyed
personal freedoms that would have been
unthinkable under the taliban millions
of young afghans and this is a young
nation now interested in social justice
interested in 21st century ideas
logged on and and connected with the
outside world through social media
so the country changed
quite a lot and the country that the
taliban fled from in 2001 is not the one
that they've conquered again in in 20
and 21. so while i think for your
average viewer afghanistan is synonymous
with military disaster with
the taliban with the drug trade the
reality is for average people at least
in urban centers in afghanistan uh the
life had changed quite
quite significantly
there was reporting khalid that joe
biden's administration didn't get all
their special immigrant visa process
sorted out earlier because they were
worried about a backlash from bringing
in thousands of afghan asylum seekers
and yet the polls show now a majority of
americans support us doing that
especially bringing in interpreters you
have thousands of afghans now
successfully evacuated you have
companies like airbnb today offering
free accommodation to thousands of
afghan refugees does that make you feel
hopeful about humanity or should we be
worried about the inevitable political
backlash to all of this from the
nativist anti-immigrant right in this
country
well we can expect that narrative to
continue but the fact is look i came to
the united states as an asylum seeker
meaning that i have not only personal
kinship with displaced people but i have
personal kinship and a personal
relationship with the moral and
political authority that this country
has traditionally brought to this issue
you know historically the united states
has been a leader
in in welcoming and protecting victims
of war and persecution and it's high
time that the united states step up
again and amp up its supports for afghan
refugees not only those who risk their
lives for u.s initiatives and u.s
objectives but also the millions of
others who work to secure their
communities and bought into the american
objectives and initiatives who are now
left behind after the americans left and
are wondering what is going to happen
with them
i'm so glad you mentioned that because a
lot of the debate has just been about
interpreters who of course did risk
their lives but a lot of other afghans
are also a threat and need our support
one last question for you khalid you
have probably done more than most in my
view to portray afghans to the world
as real people not as props in a cold
war or in a war on terror narrative for
the west and i wonder how should we
think about afghans and afghanistan now
with the taliban back in charge how do
we avoid generalizing about this country
that is so rich in its diversity it's
culture it's history and yes it's art
too you yourself are a proud afghan
artist a novelist a storyteller how do
we do that
that's been one of the things i've
really grappled with for not just in
this moment and and for for a long time
you know for a lot of people afghanistan
is synonymous with conflict with war and
persecution and displacement but the
fact is and i was just speaking to an
italian reporter earlier today who told
me that she's been to afghanistan three
times and there's no place on earth that
left an imprint on the heart like
afghanistan did it's a beautiful country
filled with beautiful people who have
poetry in their soul who are humble who
are hospitable and who are kind they
don't deserve the four years of violence
and persecution and cruelties that
they've endured and now is not the time
to turn our back to afghanistan and its
beautiful people i hope
america and her partners
stand up for americans and i ask your
readers i'm sorry your audience ask your
your audience to reach out to the
leaders
and encourage them with continued
support for afghanistan and particularly
for those who are going to be displaced
who are going to be looking for safe
territory keep our borders open and
forth for afghan refugees and continue
supporting those afghans who are fleeing
this brutal regime and are looking for
safety
we can only hope and pray khalid
hosseini thank you so much for your time
tonight appreciate it
that was the author of the kite runner
and a thousand splendid sons and i
am so delighted and privileged that we
were able to bring him back on the show
to talk again to talk about a beautiful
country with beautiful people and poetry
in their soul because
in the coming days you're going to see a
lot of images out of afghanistan of
people with guns and people with weapons
and let's not think about afghanistan
only in that way let's think about it in
the way that the likes of khaled
hosseini have portrayed it for us
hi i'm mehdi hussain thanks for checking
out our channel on youtube you can see
more of the mehdi hassan show by
clicking on any of the videos on this
screen and make sure you subscribe below
to stay up to date on the day's biggest
stories thank you for watching